I remember somebody coming up 75 years
ago as a company they like hey Kari we
have a Facebook and Twitter account I'm
like so what do you want a [ __ ]
cookie like it doesn't matter if you
have one it's what you do with it do you
remember five years ago how you couldn't
wait to get $40 worth of sushi for 20
bucks
how do you like Groupon and LivingSocial
now you hate it you hate it you hate it
because they kept selling you fraps you
didn't want and now you don't give a
rat's ass if they send you a million
dollar home for a hundred bucks
you're like delete spam get the [ __ ] out
of my inbox the internet is the gateway
drug to one-on-one relationships let me
tell you something I've scaled the [ __ ]
out of one-on-one relationships but this
thing right here if the founders of
luxury dot-com are watching right now
[ __ ] you I know that marketers ruin I
want to take away the bad stuff from
business why does it have to be bad and
by the way I love you because I view you
as an end user not because I'm [ __ ]
Mother Teresa